salut à tous je vous demande de
m'excuser je parle de ça aujourd'hui du
gac cybook deux pros 360 et je suis
désolé parce que comme tous les ans à la
même année les pollens son retour et le
mouchoir en même temps
j'en peux plus je parle du nez mais vous
inquiétez pas toujours la pêche tout va
bien alors ça ça c'est le grand retour
ça en tout cas sa marque le grand retour
de samsung dans l'univers des des pc je
vous en ai déjà parlé on les a vus web
wsa barcelone a fait une vidéo donc si
vous voulez savoir tout des specs aller
jeter un coup d'oeil à cette vidéo
intéressante vous saurez tout
aujourd'hui pas gelé bien évidemment
vous en douterez il est là je les prises
le bus avec de tous les côtés qui dit
370 1 pc en fait dont l'écran se tourner
de l'autre côté ça vous fait une
tablette donc c'est tout décret ati
s'intéressent enfin bref il ya plein
modularité ya plein de choses à raconter
donc aujourd'hui on fait quoi
aujourd'hui on se fait un tour complet
de ce samsung galaxy book deux pros 360
seul plus haut de gamme pascal galaxie
boudeuse qui exista le galaxy bout de
propria les gains et six boucles de
proue 360 avec l'écran qui pivote de
tous les côtés c'est le grand retour de
samsung c'est super intéressant est ce
qu'ils ont réussi leur retour est ce que
leur produit ça va à peu près tout faire
est ce qu'il y a des limites qu'est ce
qu'on peut en faire avec est-ce qu'il
vient trouver sa place dans l'écosystème
qu'est-ce qu'il faut l'acheter si oui à
quel prix bref vous allez voir enfin le
tour complet de la question et c'est
super passionnant
[Musique]
garder ses bons et installé on est juste
là voilà je suis là alors regardez il
est juste posé là il ya tout qui est
génial je peux dire directement on va
rentrer et france billet de danse etc en
fait cet ordinateur est très particulier
pourquoi parce qu'il est extrêmement fin
et c'est le vraiment premier truc qui
est vraiment extraordinaire ici c'est la
finesse et la légèreté ça pèse que dalle
ce truc donc ça c'est génial parce que
si vous voulez prendre un ordinateur et
que vous voulez mettre dans votre sac à
dos pour aller vous balader voilà c'est
le modèle 15 pouces 15,6 pouces et est
un modèle 13,3 pouces donc c'est
extrêmement fin et ça croyez moi c'est
vraiment génial et ça vous permet de
l'emmener facilement partout avec vous
tous cas c'est le premier truc et je
veux vraiment revenir le dire aux
phoques intéressant aussi c'est une
crise silencieuse ne l'est pas voir un
ventilateur qui va tourner à fond donc
ça c'est cool aussi au niveau du design
vient tout cas savoir c'est que dans le
dos juste en bas ici la regarder vous
allez avoir des haut parleurs donc un
petit haut parleur qui va se situer là
un deuxième haut parleurs qui va situer
là et puis là vous avez laventie un taux
qui passera par là donc c'est plutôt
intéressant le truc un point leur lot
ici c'est que ça chauffe vraiment ici et
vous le sentez il ya vraiment un côté
chaleur lorsque vous le poser sur les
genoux ça vient à bout de kershaw un peu
en était donc c'est le premier truc à
dire savoir et puis le deuxième truc à
venir savoir c'est que excusez moi j'ai
mon moniteur qui est complètement mort
donc si des fois il ya des plans un peu
floue et ma jeu je me rendrai pas
content parce que c'est tellement flou
que si ces morts dont vous voulez en
acheter un autre donc je m'en rendais
pas compte ce que j'aime vraiment ça
devrait le faire parce que la caméra la
halle devrait faire le job mais c'est
toutefois il ya un problème je suis
désolé parlant ce truc est un peu relou
ça les traces de doigts parce qu'en fait
ça prend un peu les traces de doigts ici
donc bon si vous êtes un peu maniaque
sur les bords il va falloir venir
nettoyer régulièrement parce que ça
prend quand même pas mal les traces de
doigts et il ya un autre truc qu'il faut
vraiment venir connaître et si au niveau
de ce côté légèreté maniabilité autant
il est léger autant il est très fin août
en c'est génial autant il ya quelques
petits inconvénients notamment ici au
niveau du travail pas de bruit lorsque
j'appuie la rend pas forcément s'en
rendre compte comme ça c'est vraiment
que de vous le montrer club m'a fait
flipper le courant d'air mais qui a peur
aux la honte regardez là oui parce que
vous attendez d'un contre mais lorsque
j'appuie bons d'achat sic vient peu avec
voyez là ça vient ça s'enfonce et du
coup là ça ne fait vraiment bouger leur
dit alors on n'appuie pas comme un venin
sur son ordi comme ça on s'en doute mais
en fait le truc c'est que lorsque je
suis sur mon trackpad et que j'ai pu ici
va ça me fait quand même bouger un peu
le châssis et je le vois voyez alors bon
pour autant est-ce que ça va me causer
une panne au niveau de l'ordi la réponse
est non mais voyez j'ai quand même un
ordi qui bouge un peu ici et j'ai la
même chose ici pour autant je vais pas
venir appuyer sur mon ordi ici mais
voyez ça bouge toi vachement quand même
donc c'est pas rien alors on va pas
mieux être plus appuyé comme un sauvage
mais c'est vrai que si vous appuyer sur
une touche et suite au f91 de façon des
fois un peu pour énoncer des ouvriers le
châssis qui bouge voilà donc ça c'est un
truc à connaître ben ouais c'est un truc
extrêmement fin et très jeune à un
moment il se peut que ça bouge un peu
est-ce que c'est grave non c'est pas
grave mais si vous aimez pas que ça
bouge un poil s'était pas fait pour vous
bon par contre ce que j'aime bien c'est
la charnière je trouve extrêmement
réduit cette charnière vous venez vous
le bouger d'un côté comme de l'autre ça
ne bouge pas enfin 6,7 bouge ça tourne
lui pour autant la charnière est là et
elle joue vraiment son rôle que vous le
preniez comme ça la main voyez vous
voulez par exemple le secouer un petit
peu il omet un peu plein la gueule bon
alors là j'y vais un peu sauvagement
mais sinon ça reste quand même
extrêmement solide donc ça c'est cool
dans cette position là aussi voyez ça ne
bouge pas pouvait mettre comme vous
voulez très facilement hop vous avez
quelque chose qui est très cool alors
bien évidemment lorsque vous le mettez
comme ça et bien votre clavier derrière
et complètement désactivé vous êtes
tranquille et vous n'avez plus ensuite
qu'à venir taper votre code un truc
intéressant à voir je voulais montrer
vous avez deux petits haut-parleurs
situés ici alors on est sur un petit
championnat des petits haut parleurs et
des petites grilles pour faire sentir
son procès doutre accompagnèrent
développe un son de fous furieux alors
on pourrait peut-être on va sur des
smartphones d'ailleurs on arrive à
sortir des trucs un petit peu sérieux
avec des petits smartphones mais là pour
autant voiliers et bien non c'est pas
trop le cas vous allez comprendre
pourquoi à la fois quand on comprendre à
qui s'adresse cette bécane je veux un
peu de son loyer sas et hop je le mets à
fond et là ça va arriver on écoute
[Applaudissements]
c'était très compliqué de se rendre
compte comme ça au travers d'une vidéo
d'autant plus que vous avez un micro qui
va capter qu'ils valent réinjecter
peut-être vous vous n'avez pas aussi un
truc de fou pour venir écouter derrière
tout ce qui va être médium grave dont
une fille pour se marrer et se déçoit un
peu plus basse grave on ne les a pas on
les sur son trait médium donc si on veut
venir maximiser ici l'écoutent vous
prenez des galaxies bugs quel qu'il soit
ou un casque ou alors carrément quand
vous avez une petite prise jack ici ou
n'importe quoi ça fera la faire parce
que à les écouter comme ça ici on peut
utiliser son ses haut-parleurs mais si
vous voulez visionner des films des
séries vous détendre parce que vous
allez prendre votre ordinateur vous
allez venir le poser comme ça ou si vous
voulez devenir le maître sur vos genoux
comme ça bah il ya un moment ça le fera
pas donc ça c'est un truc un peu relou
donc ça il faut le savoir après il ya un
truc qui est aussi intéressant qu'ils
ont plutôt bien fait c'est que lorsque
vous écoutez du son comme ça car
désormais la vidéo et lorsque vous plier
et vous venez vous reposer sur vos
genoux on va avoir un son qui va être un
poil plus étouffée ça change un peu la
directivité parce que forcément vous
avez ça en face de vos haut-parleurs
mais beau comme le sont pas ou par
défaut c'est pas très grave autre truc à
savoir c'est votre écran est quand même
bien réfléchissant on a une très belle
dalle c'est une dalle amoled ok mais
elle est vraiment vraiment vraiment
brillante on n'est pas sur une dalle
mate ce qui fait que si vous avez comme
moi de la lumière dans deux voiliers et
bien ça vous réfléchi tout et vous le
voyez donc bon peut-être aurait-il fallu
mettre une dalle mate cette dalle fait
le taf mais si vous avez de la lumière
dans votre dos croyez moi que vous allez
le savoir ça peut aussi être un petit
point bloquant si on préfère avoir des
dalles mates à côté de ça la dalle est
vraiment très très belle on est sur une
dalle full hd je vous ai dit moi c'est
un 15,6 pouces qui existait également 13
3 pouces surtout c'est une dalle qui est
complètement tactile et ça c'est plutôt
si intéressant ce qui fait que si je
veux me positionner comme ça refermer
ouvrir la recherche windows faire ce que
je paye mes impôts je peux le faire
alors à tactile c'est pratique mais il
ya d'autres obligés d'être accessoire
qui arrivait et qui aussi génial dans
l'histoire c'est ça et ça c'est un
aspect d'alors le s pen on le connais
parce qu'on a beaucoup utilisé sur des
tablettes galaxy tab est suite ultrahd
notamment utilisent également sur les
smartphones et soit ordinateur pourquoi
pas ça peut avoir un sens c'est marrant
de voir son dîner tas parce que comme on
est sur un pro 360 pour le tourner comme
ça et là vous pouvez le mettre sur vos
genoux pour venir dessiner griffonné
premier lot lorsque vous voulez
carrément le poser à plat donc ça c'est
cool parce que regarder je viens et je
l'utilisent comme ça avec mon ex plein
jeu je navigue se déplace alors il ya un
côté pratique qui on aime bien
l'utiliser ça évite en plus de laisser
des traces de doigts sur l'écran c'est
aussi très pratique l'autre truc qu'il
faut savoir c'est que ce respect n'est
pas connecté en bluetooth bien vous ayez
un petit bouton qui vient se situer
juste là il vous servira première
changer d'outil notamment pour mettre
une gomme si vous le souhaitez vais pas
plus donc on n'a pas de r jester on peut
pas déclencher une webcam à distance
pour autant at on besoin d'en utiliser
une webcam à distance je ne pense pas
assez sympa alors par contre tout qu'il
faut savoir c'est que si vous voulez lui
mettre un petit angle comme ça un peu
comme un petit bol studio si vous mettez
trauma il va tomber donc ça c'est truc
qui est un peu moyen et venant
l'utiliser comme ça c'est pas ou parce
que ça le fait bouger en fait le voyez
donc c'est pas forcément la meilleure
confie que la meilleure trafic si vous
voulez utiliser comme ça si vous le
prenez vous le laisser comme ça et là ça
sera bon ça bouge un peu mais ça va
c'est pas bien ton clavier trackpad ça
fonctionnera mise à pavlik ça bouge un
peu mais c'est pas très grave on oublie
facilement on a un grand crac pas très
confortable et si c'est pas du tout chà
petit carré c'est vraiment un clic comme
vous allez l'avoir clic-droit clic
gauche ça fonctionne le clavier aussi
plutôt de bonne facture ça fonctionne et
avec en plus ici un bouton pour venir
des marelles à lui mais qui fait office
de capteur d'empreintes digitales pour
venir déverrouiller de façon
complètement sécurisé votre windows donc
ça aussi c'est très bien il n'y a pas de
grandes surprises au niveau du clavier
après s'être est standard et ça fait le
taf alors quand on veut un pc on veut un
pc qui va voir de la performance pour
venir faire des soins d'ici ils ont fait
un truc intéressant ils nous ont mis un
intel core de deuxième génération c'est
un i7 on a saisi un drame c'est de la
levée dès 10h05 et on a 1 512 go de
stockage en ssd owc et config très
classique on n'a pas ici la machine la
plus puissante côté graphique c'est une
intel iris xx e donc voyez on va pas
s'amuser à faire tourner des programmes
trop compliqué trop lourd avec de la 3d
et compagnie donc pour moi c'est pas du
tout une machine qui va être fait pour
des applications un petit peu gourmand
en terme de performances on côté
graphique et sap on en parlera enfin
parce que dans quelques instants on va
regarder pour qui fait cette machine au
final donc on a quand même de quoi faire
tourner ya pas mal de choses avec un i7
ça conviendra de la bureautique un peu
lourde mais on va pas non plus aux mains
des troupes comme on est sur un
ultraportable ans se doutera qu'on n'a
pas des trucs complètement fou en termes
de connectique on al nécessaire vous
allez voir ça fait quand même pas mal le
job envie retrouvée 2 usb c'est ici là
qui vous serviront pour venir recharger
delaoutre c'est plutôt bien de ce côté
là de l'autre côté on va retrouver
également un usbco lecteur de cartes
microsd ça pour les créatifs c'est
plutôt intéressant si vous voulez venir
mettre dedans des fichiers pour faire un
peu de retouches photo si on veut vous
allez voir qu'il faut pas aller trop
loin on peut mettre aussi comme je
voulais montrer tout à l'heure au sila
une prise jack 3.5 pour brancher un
casque ça c'est aussi plutôt pas mal ce
qui m'intéresse voyez c'est que quand on
fabrique en vous mais recto de carte
micro sd c'est qui ce dit vous pouvez
être créatif vous pouvez venir faire des
photos les maîtres live here éditer vos
photos sur photoshop lightroom août vous
vouliez n'y a aucun problème pour autant
on va éviter de venir mettre des
fichiers vidéo un peu fade pour venir
les éditer parce que même si on peut
bien faire un peu de montage on va pas
aller trop loin parce qu'on risque
d'être limité qu'avec un peu par la
bécane arrivé un moment ou un autre
alors le truc qui peut être pas mal mais
aussi un peu frustrant c'est que quand
vous rechargez en usb c'est une fois que
vous avez utilisé votre sbc pour faire
de la recherche bien ça vous en
condamnant à lorsque je vous conseille
de façon ce qu'il faudra ici si vous
voulez brancher un moniteur externe
voulu faire toujours en usb s'aimait si
vous la neige dès 1000 faut prendre un
petit dock pour pouvoir dire ajouter des
portes ça peut venir star puisque je
vous parle effectivement de venir
recharger je vous montrais bloc de
charge qui est jusqu'ici savez tous les
côtés c'est un blog de charge 65 watts
il est fourni avec ces deux-là fast
charge super fast charge il signé
samsung blocs qui est compris avec en
usb c'est usb c'est de tous les côtés du
touquet plutôt sympa vous vous rechargez
assez rapidement il ya 2 pc avec déport
de charge beaucoup plus rapide c'est pas
le plus rapide du marché mais sur 65
watts et standards et ça ira très bien
juste en sachant que si vous voulez
venir charger une tablette de samsung
galaxy tab est sûre plus ou l'ultra
point fr moi j'ai rechargé ma ultra
avant sans aucun problème avec ouvert
souvenirs chargés aux smartphones de
samsung avec power sas et transverses ça
fonctionne puis vous investi une
batterie de 60 8 watts heure bon ok y'a
de quoi faire why not ici on a une
webcam full hd alors je me dis c'est que
l'une webcam full hd c'est toujours
mieux ce que j'ai sur un vieux macbook
pro de voir une webcam hd mais là au
full hd d'accord mais regardez ça
regardez ça s'ébruite et c'est pas très
beau je suis sur une petite caméra de 2
mégapixels alors effectivement c'est du
full hd mais juste pour venir échanger
rapidement mais on va pas venir se la
péter hain qualité à l'état policier ça
c'est aussi un peu dommage alors il ya
beaucoup lumière mais si je m'écarte un
peu et que je mets un peu plus selon
vous à dire tout de suite il ya le bruit
qui apparaît tous les côtés là sur le
visage 32 lycées et ouais voilà la
qualité alliée pas ici on va retrouver
un windows rôle windows rose famille
alors windows 11 je vous renvoie très
rapidement à ma vidéo que j'ai fait sur
windows os ça fonctionne bien il ya
plein de nouveautés ces pratiques se
soit pas ok on passe très rapidement là
dessus il ya tout est vachement bien ici
et qui est venu faire samsung c'est
qu'il vous ennuie du wifi 6e alors
pareil le wifi 6e je vous en parle vous
a fait une vidéo pour venir vous
expliquer ce qu'est le wifi 6e par
rapport aux 6,1 par rapport au wifi 6
donc à lester un coup d'oeil à la vidéo
qui est disponible sur la chaîne pour
tout savoir sur le wifi six autres ici
il y en a c'est super bien mais encore
faut-il que votre wifi soit wifi 6e à la
maison après que du wifi si ça fera
halte à vous inquiétez pas mais un truc
qui va au delà axa est ça qui est
intéressant avec son ordinateur de
samsung parce que si vous vous dites y'a
jamais acheté un pc il ya plein de pc un
des ultraportables il y en a plein tous
les prix mais celui-là il est
intéressant au plus pourquoi parce qu'il
prend toute sa place dans l'écosystème
de samsung vous pouvez l'utiliser par
exemple avec est bon ici je les prix
notamment une galaxy tab un site ultra
vomit reprendre une galaxy tab est
ensuite plus si vous voulez une tag à
six tablettes et suit une s est bref je
vous passe un peu l'histoire le truc qui
est super intéressant je fais mon petit
bidouillage je m'installe c'est qu'en
fait tu pouvais venir utiliser votre
galaxy s suit ultra comme une extension
de votre écran alors je vous montre
comment ça marche regardez quelle salle
est ultra ici je vais trouver mon pc
alors qu'est ce que je fais dans mag
aquitaine et ultra je viens juste là sur
le côté et là j'ai un truc qui s'appelle
deuxième écran japy dessus donc là il
est détectable ce que je fais ensuite
ici je fais un raccourci je fais la
touche windows et cas ça le propose
chercher mon deuxième écran je vois que
ma table hop elle est là japy dessus
tact collections en cours et hop
regarder voilà ce qui fait qu'en fait là
tout de suite j'ai ma souris qui va
passer d'un côté et l'eau donc le truc
bon c'est vachement cool ça me permet de
garder je prends ma fenêtre et hop je la
déplace d'un côté ou de l'autre donc ça
c'est vachement cool lorsque vous voulez
venir bosser comme ça d'un côté l'autre
mais je peux également venir faire du
numéro ring si je souhaite je viens ici
là et là lorsque je suis dans les
paramètres de windows je peux choisir
d'avoir moniteur un moniteur 2 donc là
c'est lui là c'est lui mais je peux
également se dire ah ben tiens ça ça
m'intéresse pas moi ce que je veux faire
c'est dupliquer donc je peux up
dupliquer cet affichage oulhaj avoir du
mirroring va exactement la même chose
d'à côté et l'autre alors d'intérêt me
direz vous et bien c'est par exemple si
je monte actuellement quelque chose il
peut regarder l'autre côté d'envoyer les
possibilités sont vachement étendue et
ça ça fait partie de l'écosystème
complet c'est super intéressant et ça
nous permet de le faire ici entre un pc
windows et votre tablette notamment ici
bas samsung galaxy tab et site ultra
mais ça ne s'arrête pas là ça ne
s'arrête pas là parce que je peux venir
connecter mon samsung galaxy s 22 ultra
si je le souhaite très rapidement et
très facilement alors encore gardées
c'est très simple je vais avoir ici une
app qui va s'appeler lien avec windows
sur mon pc j'ai une application génie
ici juste en bas aux raccourcis donc là
hop ça s'ouvre passer et recevoir des
appels directement de votre pc je
patiente quelques instants moi j'avais
déjà configuré j'autorise et l'envoyer
directement sur mon pc alors je n'ai pas
configuré parce que ce smartphone est
tout nouveau donkey absolument rien
dedans pour l'instant je peux bien gérer
mes messages mes photos mes applications
et les appels et ses pratiques ou avec
le truc qui est intéressant aussi c'est
que ça s'inscrit dans un écosystème dans
un ensemble complet et global vous avez
votre smartphone de votre smartphone à
votre tablette avec votre console sung
les choses monde parle claude
redescendre à côté de l'offre vous avez
également coup de chien pour venir
partager directement les éléments très
facilement et ses pratiques vous avez à
cette communication avec votre
smartphone directement sur votre pc vous
avez votre tablette qui fait office de
deuxième écran avec votre pc donc pour
moi qui ai un écosystème complet et
c'est pour ça que c'est une gamme qui
est intéressant c'est samsung il
manquait vraiment cet élément alors il
manqué cet élément oui et non il
manquait un pc c'est évident il y
manquait vraiment bien tard pour venir
compléter cette gamme chez samsung pour
autant elle n'est pas encore complète
elle n'est pas encore complète pourquoi
parce que samsung a fait chaud à
l'arrivée par de l'ultraportable avec
ces galaxies book de cette gamme galaxy
book 2 book de prod2 pro 360 vous avez
donc la possibilité sur 360 devenir le
twister de tous les côtés ce qu'on fera
pas avec les autres des différences de
taille vous avoir quelques belles
différences et c'est génial mais pour
autant si on a besoin d'un ordinateur
avec beaucoup de performances notamment
pour du gaming alors c'est pas une bête
pour fait fait pour de faire du gaming
aime bien évidemment mais si je veux par
exemple pour avoir une application un
peu plus gourmand notamment pour faire
de l'édition vidéo j'ai besoin d'aller
loin j'ai besoin beaucoup de
performances et surtout de performances
graphiques et bien et si c'est pas le
cas je lis c'est l'ordinateur qui est
top pour de la bureautique pour de la
bureautique plus pour venir et édité
quelques photos sans en mettre des
caisses pour venir à faire pas mal
d'usagers message assez léger pas
beaucoup de performances mais c'est pas
grave ça correspondra beaucoup d' usage
donc c'est super bien il n'y a aucun
problème alors pour autant s'adresse
quand même aux créatifs le fait d'avoir
cet écran qui pivote comme sa prise de
notes griffonnages dessin et compagnie
là dessus aucun problème mais si j'ai
besoin de plus de performances
graphiques je vais être limitée est ce
que pour autant ce samsung galaxy book
deux pros 360 et bien réussi pour moi la
réponse est oui parce que bien qu'on ait
des à perfection avec notamment ce petit
châssis qui veut dire bouger lorsque
vous appuyez va le trackpad en bas ou en
haut c'est normal parce qu'on a un truc
qui est très fin très léger très souple
est ce que pour autant ça veut dire
qu'il a été mal conçue je pense pas je
pense qu'il est très bien conçu au
contraire ils ont fait le choix de m la
légèreté à fond de la légèreté au
détriment certaines choses on voit qu'il
est pas parfait on a une balle qui a
beaucoup de reflets on voit que la
webcam on vole ou full hd la qualité
franchement n'est pas là elle est pas au
rendez vous on a quelques petits points
un peu faible à droite à gauche mais
dans l'ensemble je trouve bien et
surtout si vous regardez le tarif qui
est notée là-dessus ce tarif je suis
fort la version 15 pouces je suis à 1699
euros alors certes c'est un petit budget
j'en conviens que la version 13 avril 3
on est sur du 1599 euros il ya 100 euros
d'écart entre les deux après s'il vous
intéresse jusqu'au 21 juin 2022 je ne
sais pas quel moment vous calé cette
vidéo mais si vous regardez avant le 21
juin 2022 et que ça ça vous intéresse et
bien vous avez des galaxy 2 se profile
cibles profondes et parlé dans une
précédente vidéo que je vous invite à
venir voir sur ma chaîne youtube donc
machine plutôt bien plutôt complète pas
mal de ports usb c'est l'idée d'avoir
une carte microsd pourquoi pas je suis
assez satisfait je trouve ça intéressant
j'attends de voir si un jour samsung va
arriver en france avec un ordinateur à
pau être plus performant peut-être un
peu plus de performances niveau
graphique allez savoir j'en sais rien en
tout cas ce que je vois là ça ne
convainc c'est intéressant il ya une qui
est là on l'a attendu longtemps
sacrément longtemps cette gamme et ça y
est elle est là donc je compte autant
dire ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire est ce que vous avez
succombé oui non est ce que vous allez
succomber est ce que vous êtes tentés
est ce que vous pourriez aller chez
samsung parce que voyez une fois de plus
et c'est ce qui est très important ici
c'est la notion d'écosystème quand on va
acheter aujourd'hui un produit on veut
courants d'air ont donc tous
fonctionnent ensemble son pc avec sa
tablette avec sa télé avec son frigo son
lave là j'exagère un peu je dois un peu
loin mais on peut le faire avec smart
kings avec samsung et un ex ordinateur
donc pourquoi pas intéressant a beau me
dire ce que vous en pensez on se
retrouve très vite que le soin de vous
embrasse des bisous et à bientôt k o
[Musique]